good morning Hank it's Tuesday and a
little frazzled from NaNoWriMo League
but today we have to talk about
something super important your second
album this machine pones noobs best
album title ever which comes out on
November 16th and is currently available
for pre-order also we're gonna play a
game called jumping jack push up dance
move okay so I've used my connections to
obtain elite copy of your new album this
machine pones noobs and it is just so so
good and I love it and nothing against
your previous work but it's by far your
best album to date like listening to it
over and over again I've realized that
your songs aren't just funny and like
insanely catchy in the way that you wake
up singing this is a bob or this is a
concrete box they're also meditations on
how and why to be hopeful in this broken
world and yes I am seriously saying that
about an album that contains a song
called I'm not Edward Cohen I'm not
saying this as your brother but as a
fellow nerdfighter this machine poems
newbs is one of the most made of awesome
albums I've ever listened to and I'm
proud of you there I said it okay I'm so
excited about your new album that I'm
going to use the first single to
initiate the first event in the 2009
nerdfighter fitness challenge the rules
are simple how many circuits of jumping
jack push-up dance move can you do
during your song about an anglerfish
which by the way is incontestably the
greatest song ever written about an
anglerfish
by the way to be official a dance move
must feature at least two distinct
movements this is not a dance move that
is yes it's food that I once went
through live there's a guy who always
had their I'm live where the strategies
haven't been ravaged
[Music]
my life is so much better now that
because you can't hit the light have you
lived your whole life without like Nick
and only ever eaten fishing again feel
of Earth if it's all you've ever
the other TV application a reason
the teacher has to find the faint they
are always there together when it's done
the procreate c13 young that lets the
female on her side and then slowly he
becomes a sperm producing parasite and
if we could say he's rich at all he was
until she dies and until that biggie we
really never lose your song
for years this rule has got the other
focus be spare you simply do not feel
what as always there is I great to
entertain the pain is the same that if
not you and all the time can you really
call it in
I don't have any friends and I don't
have any hair butter does the inhibition
Johnson game
because you can't eat the night without
like anybody ever eaten
[Music]
clearly I need to expand my dance moves
vocabulary Hank that was the best I can
do can you beat me okay so i pre-ordered
my copy of this machine pony's noobs in
fact i pre-ordered six so I can give
them away as Christmas presents
nerdfighters you can and should
pre-order it now at dftba.com and while
supplies last you can get this
ridiculously awesome an inexpensive
bundle which includes the CD of this
machine pones noobs t-shirt and a hank
pinup poster proving once and for all
hank that you are the pinup brother and
I am the puppy brother congratulations
on the album I'll see you tomorrow
thanks